and we are now joined by world champion
magnus carlson and uh
not the best ending to the day for you i
guess magnus what's
uh what words will you use to sum up
this first day
um i would say to look on the right side
i think
i'm a little bit probably on the
unfortunate side to have the score
that i have uh but
in terms of quality of the play it
obviously has to has to improve
have you felt that the quality of the
other players
being such a strong tournament has sort
of increased that it is more
difficult now um
yeah maybe a bit i think maxim
played a very good game against me uh
but i feel most of all that my my own
play has been
has been awful okay so you want to use
the word awful
what's going to be sort of your focus
then for tomorrow to improve that
uh i i don't know yet uh but
um yeah it's it's not a great start but
i'll
uh i'll i think i'll be fine eventually
yeah do you feel confident that you can
turn this around uh with two more days
to go in preliminaries
yeah there's there is plenty of time so
again
it's not it's not great but it's um
just one day all right we're going to
let you
go to prepare for tomorrow magnus thanks
for joining us
thank you